[Music]
in good-deed gone wrong news no no good
deed goes unpunished
I didn't know the toilet you finished it
I was like no good deed mr. deeds Adam
Sandler oh yeah yeah the black hand or
something didn't have like a dead hand
and I put like boss bitten right hmm
submitted by just Eric okay huh Eric you
could do better than that Eric come on
you're married you're more than just air
man
Good Samaritan was oh my god a Good
Samaritan was murdered at Waffle House
shortly after paying for other customers
knit that's what I don't do nice [ __ ] no
don't do nice things you might get my
new Santa Claus would be the most
persecuted person on earth
I'm glad Santa Claus is not real I told
my kids that early soon as they asked
well that's daddy said no no me your mom
yeah that's it do you want the credit
right yeah yeah absolutely pay for these
bills in peppered electricity
wrap these gifts I'm gonna I'm gonna
[ __ ] my kids up really hard and create
the most delusional world ever for them
I love that everything is gonna be real
and I'm gonna try to play it up hard
magic is gonna be real dude they're
gonna live in a crazy world that's good
can't wait to see how they turn out dude
you're gonna love babysitting them
they're gonna be so pissed at you when
they find out the truth you're so
[ __ ] mad at you and then we're gonna
put on gloves and [ __ ] battle to the
death
do these fools will be in 10th Grade
giving it in 12k giving a valedictorian
speech being like now I'm going to go
hunt dragons what I have dreamed about
my whole life
right yeah joking Joe's not gonna put it
in public school he's gonna teach him in
his mud house maybe you're right that's
true but he would be valedictorian
though cuz this guy will pressure them
with weapons Victorian out of the bun
hat school that he creates in the side
the house
the thing about kids though if they grew
up in mud huts whatever Joe tells them
they'll believe it there's no one to
tell them that they're wrong everything
we believe is because somebody else told
us donated from the some dinosaur sounds
like them somebody was like wow we're
live and they found out like six years
after Jurassic Park that they all had
feathers and I think it was like [ __ ]
that looks like there's a wonderful
group out there that exists today called
the Amish people that do exactly this oh
yeah and they live in a great delusional
world do Amish people are Amish people
like helicopters that's [ __ ]
well then you don't have the fly zones
aren't over them all right like that one
M night Shyamalan movie yeah that was it
yeah you feel like you're in this old
world yeah and it's like modern day we
just bought it we spoiled the whole
entire there's a I mean it's been a
while to find out that the rest of the
world exists because like when they're
16 or something or 18 it's like Rush
Limbaugh I'll see go away for two weeks
finest in the world
yeah if they decide to live in the world
they can never come back and yeah it's
called two weeks
yeah like belong I learned about it on
orange belong yeah that's a lot of
pressure to decide in two weeks no all
right what can I get a mud Bank and I
cannot wait my decision how about they
just like see pornhub and they're like
yeah I'm [ __ ] out I'm not going back
to mama [ __ ] like you know I mean how
can they go back yo but you know what I
heard is that they're hella they're
super healthy
think of the stimulation they're super
healthy it was to learn they're super
healthy they're super strong and they're
super happy strong yeah like 15 is super
strong because they're like chopping
wood is like physical work all day
they're working outside physical labor
and then they're happier than average
Americans because that community and
social support yes but they have put a
few problems molestation problems yeah
we do - you're at your
but at least we get new breed's trill if
we're gonna have to deal with that but
we don't know how to hunt together at
all what yeah you know what the funny
thing about uber eats is like that you
can get McDonald's over to your house
McDonald's was set up because
restaurants were taking too long no
matter what if your fool is ready in
five minutes
Oh perfect and then the drive-through
was like what if you didn't have to get
out of your car and now you're like what
if you don't even have to use a car
we'll bring it to you right it's like
what if I don't want my McDonald's warm
there's a cool breeze but it's like then
there's no [ __ ] point like cold
McDonald's is like you're eating garbage
we'll raise our kids to be used to cold
McDonald's and they all know a
difference that's smart I think hot we
thought was weird
not smart they'll never know true joy
though they'll never know joy what if
you just go like this and then somebody
feeds you which is cool because they had
dope little cars yeah I loved Wally
[Applause]
everyone's fat so you're fine then hot
be more fat - yes that's pretty I could
be like in Samoan culture because
everybody's big and then I'd be like man
I fit in here that's time yeah you'll be
the skinny guy I know like this guy's
hotter than [ __ ] they're like this guy's
body fat percentage is like twenty five
percent that's really hot but is it my
house my kids are exactly put a sure way
man I pay for the Riviera I'll have to
put a shirt on but I put it on cuz I'm
embarrassed if my kids told me to put a
shirt on I go naked what sorry I read
your joke oh I will play sneeze so who's
in trouble down to the punchline
sneezing the person at the same time and
Joe was just like yeah you can never get
it back so if you it so when your kids
tell you to put all clothes what would
you do I put them on I do really
I go naked in front of them and I and
I'm like and then if they if someone try
to go oh that sexual harassment
I'd be like that's culturally
insensitive I'll see you cause dear
sexual harassment AG culturally
insensitive my old man you saw her on
all the time in tighty whities no matter
who the [ __ ] was over hey it's his house
my grandma
that pennies pulled up to here yeah brah
on no teeth burping dad I'll be like you
got a problem my my at your house or
your at my panties up to here is like a
double bra what's this article we're way
Nikki that was minutes ago words a
granny big no me bless this article tip
burping just I let the conversation go
where it needs to go cuz this one's a
sad one so oh that's right that's right
yeah I know about this so this is Craig
he was 14 I like Waffle House me too
I've never been he was killed by this
guy [ __ ] you dude 25 years old it looks
like a Jamaican lady it didn't look like
a lady I thought was way too too so this
dude this happened in Florida by the way
so we went to a Waffle House in florida
remember that kid in Orlando but this
was in Gainesville so uh Craig he was at
this Waffle House with his cousin and
then around 3:00 a.m. he was buying
meals and passing out $20 bills to
random customers in the restaurant but
then that's when this woman became
really angry because he had not paid for
her meal or given her money and then her
anger led to Ezekiel getting involved
and confronting Craig Huckabee the papal
her like that I don't know what happened
is he on his way to like take care of
her I was like you're doing a charity
thing and then somebody's like hey give
me charity to [ __ ] it's like no [ __ ]
you but I know the apathy she felt left
out so then that's when Ezekiel went
outside and then he returned with a gun
and then someone tried stopping him from
bringing outside the restaurant but he
ended up going inside anyway and he shot
him in the head hope it was worth it
you're going to jail forever now yeah he
got charged with manslaughter first
degree manslaughter
manslaughter I'm sorry first degree
murder oh yeah that's not an ass today
yeah
Jesus oh my goodness how could you be
how could you feel entitled to someone
paying for your food a stranger do it in
Waffle House is so [ __ ] cheap it's
insane
I need literally 20 bucks probably paid
for everyone yeah I need to know how the
argument went down because it probably
wasn't about the waffles like they
probably felt disrespected some were in
the conversation needs like awful
irrational it's Florida yes authorities
right now they're trying to figure out
even though those waffles are to die for
but like you know well he did that but
maybe not that he died so right now
authorities are trying to find out if
they knew each other before this
argument happens yeah that makes more
sense
yeah there's something missing like no
one's gonna be shot over maple syrup you
know maybe I mean dude it like Nikki
said it's Florida but not even bet
something to diss on Florida it's just
like every time you read a crazy ass
story and it's like Florida there's some
drugs in it just like ah yeah
desensitized it's like the maze I should
affect like yeah there was a time when
Mike Tyson didn't even banging anything
he did like member the face had to when
that was like weird cuz I all Mike Tyson
got a face how do you like oh that's
Mike Tyson that has a little for it Mike
Tyson just bought a [ __ ] tiger it's
like yep Mike Tyson tiger it's on brand
it's a Florida's on brand random no
there's no story you could hear that
it'd be in happened in Florida you like
oh it's cuz poor to get shot so often
that I'm just like it's what's worked on
me I'm Michael yeah yeah it was like
this this woman Avery child's face off
in Florida bath salts this guy got out
of jail in Florida and then stole a car
in the jail parking lot and got caught
in the parking lot can rebooked and put
back on the stack oh and I was like BAM
and they were like in Florida I was like
ah he's like how the [ __ ] am I supposed
to get out of here this actually have
you thought about that before no you
haven't guessed the only thing is I've
been to Florida and it's not even bad
that's what I don't understand it's
worse here you weren't there and long
enough it's nice ZV maybe it's the
humidity because the humidity makes you
crazy while do you ever put it in your
night trend that was like a Florida man
in the near birthday
you see what article Koza but it's also
what the media does how they do Florida
man Florida woman all the [ __ ] like the
repetition of that works on your brain
over time yeah how about California man
you never hear that now you know that
California man you do read Riverside man
yeah my kidnapper in Hawaii was a
Florida man kidnappers from tomorrow
yeah Oh seen year old daughter out and
like walk around walking alone at night
no he was a very nice man he bought me
ice cream and he bought me souvenirs and
then he wanted me to go with him to a
really creepy parking garage and where
his car was and I was like that's what
you drew the line yeah ice cream yes
person and this is why you don't shelter
your kids no I show them my kids my kids
are gonna be murderers how do you
shelter them what do you do I just I
don't really let them they don't really
play outside that much you don't want to
play outside or you don't let him but
they don't want to they don't want to oh
yeah they don't want they never actually
they never asked they don't walk to the
store ever when I was a kid we used to
walk to the store used to be I don't
walk to school but the modern kid is
like they don't want to go outside
there's no hangout I don't want to go
outside either but they made me but ride
my bike to school I liked going outside
no we liked outside or they just forced
us out of the house so we just way
outside but we didn't have distractions
like they like the kids now they have
like I thought a good movie dude we had
like Game Boy the games didn't last that
long dog well the thing is I think the
difference is technology allows you to
play with your friends now without
having to go to their house yeah before
you had to play two players we have to
be sitting next to each other then we
have to ask your mom for a ride and just
like half the time she's like no and
then you're like why well for no reason
so then you had to get a bike to get a
vehicle to get to your friend for more
hard as [ __ ] - yeah Turtles yeah yeah
and then and then you died it just like
I can't play this anymore cuz you don't
have the patience you can't even say
one time back in our day you couldn't
save yeah beats a whole sonic in one
city dude in LA
like imagine your kid asks you to take a
ride here to their friend's house but in
LA takes 45 minutes to go [ __ ] five
miles so it's like no you're not calling
your friends friend lives in Venice no
they find them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]